[Musique]
j'aimerais vous parler moi aujourd'hui
du chemin de vie que l'on a à parcourir
nous le savons nous ne sommes que de
passage sur cette terre et chacun
d'entre nous a une mission à accomplir
la mienne en tant que jeune femme et
danseuse artiste chanteuse et de donner
du bonheur aux gens que ce soit à mes
proches ou au public
on dit souvent de moi que je suis un
rayon de soleil et oui je suis plutôt
chaleureuse et pleine d'énergie mais
rassurez-vous comme tout le monde je
suis imparfaite et je dois souvent
recharger mes batteries pour faire le
plein d'énergie et revenir en pleine
forme au devant de la scène
et d'ailleurs me voici aujourd'hui face
à vous après un parcours d'une trentaine
d'années qui n'a pas été de tout repos
mais qu'est-ce que j'en ai appris des
choses surtout tomber les vies mais
moins midi Aster met encore la passer
alors que fut un temps
épreuve après épreuve je me disais mais
jusqu'à quand mon Dieu je suis fatigué
j'en peux plus de subir ma vie entre le
fait de me faire jeter d'une tournée en
Inde le jour du réveillon de Noël alors
que j'avais que 13 ans le décès de ma
grand-mère la maladie de mon compagnon à
peine 24 ans la reprise des études la
séparation le harcèlement au travail
bref je vous passe les détails
mais en tout cas tout ça pour vous dire
que dès notre plus jeune âge nous sommes
confrontés à des épreuves à l'école on
subit des moqueries des injustices la
compétition on doit faire face à
d'autres épreuves liées aux attentes de
nos parents avoir un certain niveau à
l'école devenir responsable veillez sur
nos frères et sœurs aux attentes de la
société également entrer dans le moule
comme on dit
notamment obtenir des diplômes se marier
faire des enfants à tel âge avoir une
vie sociale mais également à nos propres
attentes et bien souvent nous sommes
très exigeants vis-à-vis de notre
personne et nous doit affront tout ça là
alors que nous connaît pas nous
nous-mêmes pour y parvenir c'est un
travail de longue haleine tout au long
de notre vie nous apprenons à nous
connaître car on évolue alors il faudra
sans cesse faire des efforts avancer
s'exprimer écouter observer apprendre
réapprendre persévérer et revoir sa
façon de penser
tout au long de notre vie nous sommes
amenés à vivre des choses qui qu'elles
soient banales comme se lever le matin
et aller travailler des choses plus
intenses comme réaliser son plus grand
rêve ou un projet qui nous tenait à cœur
depuis des années d'autres choses qui
peuvent être éprouvantes même aller
faire un simple check-up chez le médecin
et du jour au lendemain devoir faire
face au cancer mais diazote bien que
c'est que les faciles pour nous les pas
forcément évident pour notre camarade et
cette nous de dalons va gagner bien
gérer peut-être que nous a son place
nous nous régalerez
dans tous les cas ces expériences de vie
sont tout de même nécessaires elles nous
façonne elle forge notre caractère nous
fragilise parfois mais c'est à nous de
décider de ce que l'on souhaite faire de
ces expériences à nous de savoir ce que
l'on veut en retirer une leçon de vie
une étape de plus sur notre parcours
je pense que dans tous les cas il faut
rester focus sur nous il faut sans cesse
positiver facile à dire
avancer persévérer et oui et du coup
pour ce faire
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
parce que on a toujours des épreuves sur
notre vie comme je vous disais
et pour y parvenir et bien on doit
parfois faire des chutes se relever et
puis faire face à nos peurs quand on est
face à on doit faire face à un imprévu
pardon on doit trouver des solutions
alors par exemple récemment j'ai pris
froid et j'avais la voix cassée alors
que je devais enregistrer ma voix au
studio pour mon prochain titre et du
coup j'étais complètement dévastée
j'étais dépité et ma première réaction a
été mais au télé n'est pas possible tout
le temps sa mère à chaque fois que j'ai
une opportunité à chaque fois que j'ai
une porte qui s'ouvre à moi je me
retrouve avec une porte fermée derrière
mais jusqu'à quand j'en ai marre en fait
j'ai l'impression de toujours faire un
pas en avant et trois en arrière
j'ai dû me poser un instant
et au lieu d'annuler mon rendez-vous et
ben j'y suis allé
j'y suis allé avec ma voix cassée mais
j'enregistré une voix témoin ce qu'on
appelle pour que le reste de la team
puisse avancer sur leur travail alors
les choses ne se sont pas présentées
comme je l'imaginais mais on a tout de
même pu avancer
moins vite que prévu c'est clair mais en
tout cas j'étais très contente d'avoir
trouvé une alternative face à cette
imprévu
et moi je pense que
chacun n'a son gaillard chacun a son
étoiles son karma mais nous toutes nous
toutes les capables trouve la force en
nous pour nous avancer pour nous voir
les choses à notre manière pour nous
rendre à
un moment donné je me suis posé une
question mais Aurélie comment tu fais
pour donner du bonheur aux gens comment
tu fais pour chanter danser pour les
autres être tout sourire alors que tu
n'en as ni la force ni l'énergie
la néantio fait toute affaires ou les
speed ou travaille dans le bureau ça
fait la danse ou d'un coup ça chantait
ou à prendre texte ou parce casting
automne film ou organise la fête en
famille repente camarades ou les à
droite à gauche
un moment donné les gars et puis oui
non mais vraiment du coup ben j'ai dû
apprendre à prendre du temps pour moi
alors c'était pas quelque chose dont
j'avais l'habitude
me retrouver face à moi-même mais en
tout cas c'est pas quelque chose de
grave au contraire je prends plaisir
maintenant à prendre du temps pour moi à
faire les choses pour moi et seul avec
moi-même alors que depuis toute petite
j'ai été baigné dans la foule dans la
musique le bruit toujours entouré de
mille et une personne
mais en tout cas ça me fait du bien
maintenant de me retrouver face à
soi-même c'est pas
c'est pas simple à faire en tout cas de
se retrouver face à soi mais ça nous
permet de nous recentrer
ça nous permet de nous recentrer et
de réfléchir sur ce qui est essentiel
je pense qu'on doit voir plutôt notre
verre à moitié plein et non à moitié
vide que chaque jour nous devons nous
fixer des objectifs même si ce sont de
petites choses à réaliser c'est pas
grave vaincre nos peurs parce que ça
allait dans la tête ça et puis repousser
nos limites garder la foi en Dieu pour
les croyants mais en soi surtout parce
que nous sommes tous capables de
réaliser de belles choses de grandes
choses pour nous et pour les autres
alors oui nous les capables si je te
crois pas aux autres s'il faut garder
dans la glace avec détermination dit oui
moi elle est capable
après moi oui moi elle est capable oui
alors ça il fait ça un petit peu tous
les jours bon si ça tu oublies tous les
jours elle est pas grave mais de temps
en temps
et du coup ça va nous permettre
d'avancer en tout cas quand vous êtes
face à une épreuve
on s'est dit souvent tu avais jamais je
vais y arriver encore c'est pas possible
mais
je vais je vais pas pouvoir surmonter
cette épreuve c'est trop oui parfois
c'est trop mais gardez à l'esprit garder
en tête qu'il y a toujours pire que
notre situation que tellement de gens
souffrent plus que nous tellement de
gens galèrent plus que nous
alors du coup ça nous permet de garder
la tête froide et d'avancer
au lieu de se laisser sombrer allons
chercher la lumière au bout du tunnel
mais s'il attirent ça en place si
assises injoignaient plus un outil bleu
et reste comme ça si nous sa parole la
lumière au bout du tunnel si nous lève
pas nos deux bouts de pas pour pas sur
l'interrupteur la lumière il allume pas
tout seul
ça l'éclaire en tout cas nous sommes
maître de notre destin j'en suis
convaincu on peut y arriver grâce à la
persévérance
quoi qu'il en soit l'univers a de belles
choses à nous offrir même si elle a des
choses à nous apprendre des leçons de
vie
mais je pense que qu'on peut y arriver
en persévérant on reste éveillé
merci
[Applaudissements]